i'm madison mills this is bloomberg
quick take whitney houston's music is
coming back to life in the form of an
nft digital artist diana sinclair is
showcasing houston's legacy in an
exclusive icon collection by one of it's
a green music nft platform the art piece
will include a never-before-heard song
by whitney houston which is set to be
auctioned off we're joined now by josh
james co-founder of one of to discuss
the collection and to hear more about
the digital art movement as a whole josh
thank you for being here just give me
the details of this incredible whitney
houston nft what do we have going on
here
yeah well first of all thanks for having
me you know it was uh it was one of
those phone calls you you want to get uh
i got a call from a friend about six
months ago and
they said you know we have this
unreleased whitney houston song she
recorded in 1980 when she was 17. are
you interested
and uh you know after i got my jaw off
the floor i was like yes you know
where's the contract how do i sign it um
and you know it went down a whole a
whole path for us of uh
of this collection they were dropping it
was obviously very very exciting as a as
a kid who was sort of uh raised in the
80s uh with houston it was uh it was
very exciting as you can imagine of
course and it's more than just this song
i mean obviously i and everyone else
wants to hear the never before heard
song but it doesn't stop there right
yeah you know we we knew we wanted to
sort of combine it with the crypto
artist and it's just amazing sometimes
you just get lucky
something in the stars happened which
was we found this amazing um up and
coming out obviously she's already she's
already here she's very successful now
uh crypto artist named diana sinclair
she just happens to be 17 she happens to
be from the same hometown as whitney
houston
um
same age as whitney when she made the
song it's just this beautiful story and
so she she made she got really inspired
by it and made these amazing pieces that
go with the collection so how does one
determine the price tag of something
like this i mean you can't really put a
price on a never-before-heard whitney
track
yeah you know it yeah it's going to be
an auction which uh starts tonight at 8
p.m um at oneup.com and
you know there's really no way to know
we've had people uh make some pretty
wildly different speculations on on what
it may sell for um
we will see quite exciting no way to
know nothing like this has really ever
been auctioned before that we were able
to find yeah yeah well i mean what does
that look like let's say someone you
know gets gets this nft i mean are they
able to
do what they want with it can they like
make a tick tock and use this as a sound
what happens from there
no you know it's there are there are a
few limitations um it is a copy of the
song um so you own the right to
essentially enjoy and listen to the song
so if you want to have a cocktail party
over and invite 50 people and play the
song you certainly can um you you know
it's supposed to be private that's uh
that's what the estate wanted and we
respected that and so you know you would
not be able to say upload it to youtube
or something like that
what would stop someone from doing that
is it a legal action thing
you know there's a couple things that
would stop it first of all if you spent
a substantial amount of money to acquire
the only copy of a whitney houston song
you probably aren't a person that's
going to upload it to youtube because it
could you know take away sort of the
specialness of it um but yeah you know
if it got uploaded just like any other
copyright material if i got uploaded um
the system would just sort of auto take
it down got it yeah and um forgive me
because you are of course the expert on
this josh but let's say we're talking
about a listening party in the metaverse
do you see that being a thing that could
happen could there be you know a
cocktail party in one room of the
metaverse that only a certain select few
are allowed in and then just those few
get to hear the song
yeah that's certainly possible that's
certainly possible i must tell you i
have heard the song which many of the
people at my company are jealous about
and
whoever gets to hear the song will be
very very excited it's really really a
wonderful song i have to say i've been
in the music business for for a long
time and uh demos by emerging artists
are not always very good to be honest
with you yeah but this is really really
an amazing song and you sort of hear the
huge whitney voice even at 17 and i got
quite emotional the first time i heard
it i have to say so yeah i mean i can i
can only imagine it sounds incredible
josh tell me more about one of why is it
different and what is next for you guys
yeah so one of is a green nft platform
you know we really went into it um
trying to solve sort of the three major
problems that artists were having and
sort of what was at the time the
emerging uh nft space um and you know
those those three problems were the
green angle you know the nfts are bad
for the environment it's sort of what
was out there and so you know we meant
on a blockchain called tesos and when we
meant an nft it's two million times more
energy efficient than sort of other
platforms he uses the same amount of
energy as sending out a tweet so we like
to say people can't complain about us on
twitter because their their tweets use
more energy than our nfts so the second
thing is just the price point we we mint
on tezos and you can nfts for a penny so
you can sell five dollar nfts 10 bar
empties 15 empties on the whitney
collection you probably noticed that we
sold these the initial collection for 17
uh it sold out in 43 seconds um we
wanted to make the price point low so
that's the second thing and the third
thing is just that we built a platform
that's not for crypto people it's
actually for fans you don't need to know
how to format ethereum wallet or any of
this kind of crazy stuff you can use a
credit card to make a purchase you can
also use crypto to make a purchase we
take bitcoin ethereum uh et cetera but
we we make it very easy for you to
onboard which is sort of the third thing
that artists really care about
you know and what what's ahead for us
sorry no no go ahead tell me yeah
what's ahead for us is you know we have
you probably may have seen that we have
a deal with the grammys for the next
three years so we're going to be doing
nfts of the grammys which we're very
very excited about um and we're going to
be moving into some other spaces which
we'll be uh we'll be talking about on in
in future months
okay no no breaking news for us there
josh um but tell me a little bit about
that that decision to
make it really accessible right like you
said you can just use a credit card you
don't have to have an eth wallet how did
you come to that decision and in the
crypto
bro community are they cool with you
doing that or are people like why would
you not just stick to nfts and crypto
being hand in hand
yeah you know i think most people in the
community want to see the community grow
um you know 97
of the world does not own crypto and is
not in the crypto space and so that's a
massive massive market and we think the
barrier to entry is both technical which
we think we've solved but also sort of
mental which is a lot of people just
don't think crypto and nfts are for them
they don't understand it it's too
confusing it's too hard to get into um
and you know we really think that um
bringing a few hundred million people
into the crypto space with low price
easy fun collectibles is a way to bring
them into the to the community and so
you know there's always going to be a
few people on the edge who want their
their club to be the smallest club
possible and all of that but you know
the majority of the community is
interested in expanding the space yeah
of course that that only makes sense
josh uh and my final question to you any
hints you can give me about the song i
know you said that it's great even
though uh whitney was 17 when she
recorded it but any little nuggets you
can give me here
yeah you know it's very dancy and poppy
and um
you know her first album was very sort
of soulful and gospel based and i could
sort of see why this song may not have
fit into that but if this song was
released right now it would be a hit it
makes you want to dance around and and
it's got a great vibe to it so oh josh
what an amazing tease and i know that
i'm not going to be able to hear it so
i'm devastated but i appreciate you
joining and sharing that with us thank
you so much
thanks for having me that was josh james
from one of